Lakers beat writer for the LA Times kind
enough to join us from Dallas Tonya how
is morale around the Lakers it was
pretty good yesterday we were in
practice they were doing their
half-court shot competition that they do
sometimes at the end of practice you
know we've gotten such a positive guy
that he keeps things pretty positive
with the team so around the team the
players and the coaches things were
pretty positive yesterday all right
let's say I've been out of the country
the last month and I come back in and I
say Tonya give me the CliffsNotes
version what's happened with my Lakers
how would you sum that up well there
were there was there were two incidents
that could call crews potential team you
know first Jeanie buss removed her
brother and Mitch Kupchak as the general
manager and brought in Magic Johnson and
then her brother's her older brothers
Johnnie and Jim tried to take the team
back from her hmm
and she didn't let them okay but how
does this affect the team if I'm a Laker
fan okay there's turmoil in the front
office here but is that going to impact
this team how does it impact this team
as they move forward well the way it
impacts the team is that this
organization was so stable for so long
with Jerry Buss running things you know
things were the things were in a it's
not a lot changed up at the top and
Jerry buses trust wanted in in his
stress he said that he wanted Jeanie
buss to be running the team you know
after his death and things have just
kind of become very unsettled there now
I don't think that legally I don't think
her brothers have any like to stand on
right now so this is this is kind of
messy and there's a lot of family drama
playing out you know she wrote this
letter in the court filings that called
her brother Jim unfit to run the Lakers
and there's a lot of that kind of drama
going on but I think once they get get
into court and resolve this she's gonna
be in charge and moving forward she's
gonna be making the decisions about the
team and things will return to
and stability it seems like Magic
Johnson's role is going to be how would
you define that well he's the president
of basketball operations which means
that everything stops with him you know
he's he's the final he has a final say
on the draft he has a final say in free
agency
they're bringing in general manager Rob
pálinka who is I think right right now
he's working to divest from his agent
business and once he comes in he's going
to be doing a lot of the day-to-day a
lot of the kind of dealings with other
general managers and things like that
but the sign will say on what players
come to the Lakers what decisions they
make that's all lies that's all going to
be as Magic Johnson could you see a
scenario where Phil Jackson comes back
here Tania I can't I think that if that
were going to happen
I mean I think that his breakup with
Jeanie buss that told us that that's not
going to happen because the distance I
think was a big part of that and if he
was going to be calling back to the
Lakers anytime soon or you know any time
at all I don't think I think they would
have been looking to that as something
that would change if they were still
together do you think that's a
possibility I yeah I mean I think that
if they were if they were still together
I mean I think they would have stayed
together if that were a possibility if
that answers your question okay
and with Luke Walton he's he how would
you grade what he's accomplished so far
here in his rookie season um I don't
know I mean he's done he's done what he
set out to do I mean he's got a lot of
handicaps it's been a very frustrating
season for him because they he's not
used to losing if you look at all the
teams that he played on very rarely it
was he on a team that was out of the
playoff hunt with 30 games to go but you
know he's kept things very positive the
players still really believe in him in a
way that towards the end they didn't
really connect with Byron Scott and in a
similar way because he was he didn't
have sort of the positive tone that Luke
Walton has
byron didn't like young players so that
certainly didn't bode well for byron
when you have a full team of young
players he was hard on them
yeah and that was definitely difficult
for some of the young players and and
Walton has a really good sense of he can
read a room really well so he knows what
these guys need and responds to that you
did a profile on on Luke Walton recently
in the only times I not really did you
do something on Larry Bird Magic Johnson
okay it was really well done and I'm and
that's where I saw your name and I
thought you know I'd love to have you on
to talk about the Lakers does Luke
Walton still think Larry Bird is better
than Magic Johnson probably but he was
around bird since he was what five years
old I think that when his dad went to go
play for the Celtics in the 80s Larry
Bird and he's just it's it was funny I
actually was I had the interview
scheduled with Larry Bird right around
when Lakers shooter on was opening up
for availability and I asked the Lakers
PR staff can I can Luke wait is like if
he can't it's fine but if he can that
would be great because I have to go talk
to Larry Bird and I was told he said
only four layers it was well done I
really enjoyed this story and had
forgotten all about that that here's
Luke growing up and his dad's a Celtic
and Larry Bird is there visiting and he
falls in love with Larry Bird and would
would have those arguments with all of
his friends in San Diego that Larry was
better than Magic Johnson so have fun
good luck with the beat there Tonya and
thanks for joining us no problem all
right
Tonya Ganguly who covers Lakers for the
LA Times the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience